[Music]
regarding the upcoming sequel to joker
fans are of mixed opinions some would
have preferred the movie with joaquin
phoenix which has been detached from the
dceu to be a unique experience while
others are extremely wary of the planned
musical version either way joker felia
do is definitely coming according to
deadline this week there is now a
confirmed release date for the sequel to
the most successful r-rated movie of all
time as was already suspected the film
will be released in u.s theaters on
october 4th 2024 which is the date that
warner brothers had previously reserved
for an unnamed comic book adaptation
unfortunately so far there was only bits
and pieces of information about the
content one clue to the plot is the
title felia do which refers to a mental
disorder in which one sick individual
transmits their symptoms to another many
people consider this to be a reference
to the appearance by harley quinn which
is now confirmed she will be in the
movie big time played by lady gaga there
are also unconfirmed reports that much
of the action will take place in the
infamous arkham asylum this would make
perfect sense since the joker and harley
quinn met in this very place in the
comic book moreover the end of joker
also took place in the asylum now we are
eagerly awaiting more news and look
forward to joker philiadoo which were
released on october 4th 2024
last march legendary impressed fans of
visually stunning action with godzilla
vs kong in between it was even the most
profitable film released during the
pandemic since the success of the big
clash between the two giants several
other projects from the monster verse
have been in the works including the
animated series kong skull island on
netflix the godzilla live action series
on apple tv plus and of course another
big screen sequel to follow up godzilla
vs kong filming for the latter began a
few days ago and as with godzilla vs
kong and kong skull island it is being
filmed in australia as reported by the
australian magazine screen queensland
the shooting takes place on the gold
coast in the southeast of the state of
queensland the news channel 7 news
brisbane even claims to have found out
that the setting is to serve as a film
template for the beach of rio de janeiro
which would mean that a location for the
new monstroverse movie has already been
set the short video at least suggests
that a very large creature is running
towards the beachgoers however not a
whole lot is known about godzilla vs
kong 2 yet neither whether actors from
the previous movie will come back nor
the exact plot we only know about the
return of director adam wingard and that
the film may be titled son of kong
recently the potential working title
origins was also leaked still it is hard
to tell how trustworthy the source is
the release date is scheduled for march
15 2024 so there is still plenty of time
for new details and rumors anyway
the eternals actor patton oswald was a
guest on the today show just some days
ago there the 53 year old made waves
when he suddenly spoke about the eternal
sequel the 10 second clip of a statement
quickly went viral and many were
surprised at how naturally he expressed
himself about the sequel he literally
said that the people in charge had
announced an eternal sequel which would
once again be directed by chloe zhao in
conclusion he hopes for more adventures
of star fox and pip especially because
marvel had a lot of info up its sleeve
at the last comic con but did not say
anything about eternals too oswald's
statement truly came out of nowhere the
question is when and in what form this
possible sequel could be released as
actually only one slot can be considered
in phase six of the mcu therefore we are
still in need of clarification and it
remains to be seen whether oswald simply
made a slip of the tongue or whether
there really is some truth behind the
sequel
this news surprised the entire movie
industry this week warner brothers
cancels the release of batgirl as the
movie giant announced in a statement the
film including streaming in theatrical
release has been completely scrapped the
peculiar thing is that the film is
already fully shot and the test
screenings were already well underway
the reason cited was a change in
strategy among management rather than
poor test screenings or other concerns
related to the quality of the planned dc
film at the same time the company
informed that they were very satisfied
with the final product and the work of
the people involved but that they had to
take this step nonetheless the same also
applies to the release of the scoop
sequel which also fell victim to the new
strategy particularly unhappy about this
seems to be the creator tony cervone he
reported the film was as good as
finished and was devastated by the
decision some suspect a common theme
behind this because warner wants to
focus on high-class theatrical
blockbusters like the batman or dune in
the future and less on exclusive titles
at hbo max with smaller budgets batgirl
with its increased production budget of
close to 90 million dollars may not have
been big enough or at least it does not
seem to meet warner standards for a high
budget blockbuster spectacle the driving
force here is david zasloff who has been
the new ceo since the merging of warner
brothers in discovery inc and he wants
to turn his back on many smaller
productions now and in the future but
plenty of industry insiders suspect
there's even more obvious reason behind
the scrapping of batgirl and scoob 2
holiday haunt involving nothing other
than money as reported by variety and
others warner brothers discovery and the
team around david zazlov are using this
approach as a way to save taxes on the
fresh corporate merger by canceling the
two movies they can reclaim many
millions in tax expenses which should
very much please the accounts at warner
brothers discovery this step is
dependent on the fact that no profit can
be made on either movie which also means
they cannot ever be released
commercially a rather complicated matter
one that many experts agree is indeed
unlikely to have any content-related
reasons but rather fiscal ones at
present this approach is causing quite a
lot of criticism in hollywood since in
the end the bear figures seem to be far
more important than the work of many
thousands of people who spent a
considerable amount of time on
completing the films still it is
unlikely that the outcry over the tax
strategy will force the release of the
two movies what are your thoughts about
david zaslov and the cancelling of the
two films do you understand the reasons
behind it or are you also among the
people who disapprove of this strategy
feel free to let us know in the comments
fans were astonished when they saw none
other than ben affleck in an instagram
post by jason momoa at the end of last
week with the posting he confirmed that
affleck will star as batman in aquaman
in the lost kingdom and will thus
substitute michael keaton funnily enough
there were already pictures of affleck
on set a few days earlier after visitors
caught sight of the 49 year old during a
guided tour of warner studios that said
affleck's role is believed to be rather
small with some sources even speaking of
just a single scene the main reason is
said to be the ongoing troubles with the
flash which has already been wrapped the
film was constantly pushed back and was
originally intended to be released ahead
of aquaman in the lost kingdom this
would have allowed michael keaton to
celebrate his return as batman in the
flash after 30 years before making
another appearance in the aquaman sequel
the decision to have affleck replace
keaton was apparently made after the
test greetings of aquaman 2 where the
audience was confused by the fact that
michael keaton was featured as batman
without much notice and as if it were a
matter of course thus the more viable
solution was to simply replace keaton
with affleck in the handful of scenes in
aquaman 2 although that still raises a
lot of questions regarding the flash it
seems that the jury is still out on the
film starring the scandalous actor ezra
miller as there's been no final decision
on how to proceed with the flash after
the 29 year old's recent incidents the
anticipated release date for the flash
is planned for june 23 2023 while
aquaman in the lost kingdom will hit
theaters about three months earlier on
march 17 2023
the tomb raider series has enjoyed great
popularity among video game fans for
over 25 years now most notably the early
games featuring the main character lara
croft have since become iconic in the
gaming scene in 2001 and 2003 there were
the first movie adaptations in which
angelina jolie starred as the
archaeologist with aristocratic origins
however the films failed to impress many
fans which is why they distanced
themselves from further adaptations
after two movies it was not until 2018
that they dared to give it another try
with a reboot featuring alicia vikander
in the leading role it was well received
overall and was also more successful at
the box office than its two forerunners
mgm and warner brothers thus made plans
for a sequel as early as 2019 and
supposedly pre-production was already in
full swing before the pandemic upset all
plans a last sign from the production
was in may 2021 when screenwriter and
director misha green gave a brief update
via twitter however it has been made
clear for a few days now that the sequel
with vikander is definitely not going to
happen the reason for this is the loss
of the movie rights from mgm since no go
ahead for the film was given until may
2022 and hence according to the contract
clause the movie rights returned to
graham king and its production company
gk films at the same time it became
known that they were now looking for a
new actress so it remains to be seen how
the tomb raider franchise will proceed
this was our news for the week looking
for more content on our channel then
take a look at our new adorable
originals episode featuring all the best
groot and baby groot moments in order to
prepare yourself for the i am groot
series available for streaming on disney
plus starting on august 10th 2022
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]